now let's have a look at number five now
before I draw the whole team okay let's
think about what it means just look at
this guy just look at this guy over here
the modules are simple straight module
sub zip plus three okay let's just think
about him for a movie because we already
know we already know what this guy is
right so it stands to reason that this
is very very similar how is it different
now we know what this looks like we know
what that looks like okay what would you
guess that looks like how would it be
different so if I wrote this with the
X's on I wise
like that ok this 3 right he's a real
number it's a real number so really this
whole complex number has like this whole
bit here the X and the 3 as they're that
whole bit is real like do you agree with
that so what this really is is um
instead of X plus I Y is equal 5 sorry
bought xmas online it's really mod of X
plus 3 plus by one do you agree with
that
ok yeah I think first thing remember I
said this good form all your knowledge
of graphing already right if I wish you
to compare something like saying y
equals x squared which you all know what
that looks like and y equals x plus 3
squared that's that's like the
difference here you see that almost the
difference between these two guys same
shape translated 3 units to the left 3
and to the left so this is a circle
radius 5 Center margin this is also a
circle radius 5 Center at negative 3
that's where it's gone
ok so what this really means we need to
look at something like this right this
is not the distance from the origin but
this is the distance from the origin
okay this is not the distance from the
origin this is the difference distance
from what was the center of the circle
you the center of the SEC was negative 3
okay so actually this is something we're
putting maybe underneath here
right generally speaking if I said to
you do you remember this is the distance
from negative 3 section negative
fighting-men right so if I said - you
said - tell me what's that right yeah
this is the distance from W right so in
fact a better and more helpful way of
writing this is actually as Z take away
zero it looks it is the origin right
distance from the origin right distance
distance from negative three distance
from negative three distance from where
is this okay so you can be careful
because this is minus sign is kind of
hiding there so let me rewrite this
whole line in a way that's a little more
easy to interpret this is the distance
from just taking out a minus sign so
therefore it's gonna make 1 minus 2i do
you see how there's a double in you then
distance from there is the same as the
distance from them do you hear that
ok now this is really cool cuz I know
exactly where these points are now we
can draw our conference play
now naked3 I know where that is one two
three
there it is and so I'm just gonna put up
not leave that it's not late whatever
where is this one most - I won - - I -
that's ok so if this is 1 - 2 I
I want all of the complex numbers that
satisfy this equation that are the same
distance from here as they are from here
now there's some easy points that I know
there's at least one easy way that's
very obviously the same distance from
this point as is from that point and the
easiest point I can think of is the
midpoint right the midpoint by
definition it's exactly halfway between
those two do you agree
but there is after all an infinite set
of other points that are still the same
distance where else could I draw one
yeah you're gonna get see that interval
I just drew every point on the
perpendicular bisector right like if you
if you pick out point that you should
just draw it right the distance from
here to negative 3 is the same as the
distance from there to 1 minus 2i and
you can say the same about any other
point on there that's you like so now I
know what it's gonna look like how do I
find out the equation of this being
precise
I could I could like find it like I know
I know what this thing is I find that
dissect up that's option one option two
is as we've been doing for the rest of
this I could just look at this guy and
deal with it
algebraically I could do that goodnight
I'm not saying it's the best way but
it'll work right
I won't finish all the working out
because you can see this is going to be
modular stop X plus iy - I'm going to go
back to that one prostitute i x+
plus three now some of you got to this
point you're like no no now what do I do
well it's a modulus right it's a
distance to a point so you're going to
go to Pythagoras the distance formula
right you just need the real part is a
real part X plus one that's real and you
need the that's X minus one actually I'm
sorry X minus one and you're going to
need the imaginary part which is y plus
two
that's the distance will be off but
there isn't it right you'll like oh man
this is gonna be a big course right it
is for a second what about everything
what's going to be underneath my square
root X plus three plus
now it doesn't tear but keep in mind
number one the two square roots are
going to go right and then because
you've got a monic quadratic you want to
coordinate their 1/4 all the X Squared's
and Y squares are going to disappear
they better disappear because I'm
expecting a straight line Yeah right now
I think some of you were found at these
wake was what like 2 plus 2 X plus 1 G
that was not a bad estimate was it ok so
you do need to find to make sure that
you know how to manipulate you G to find
y equals 2x plus 1 but clearly you are
an advantage if you thought
geometrically you know I know where I'm
going I know what I'm expecting you can
imagine with this algebra down here
should be easy to get a sign wrong
happens all the time to the best
mathematicians careless error but if
you've got this drawing and then the
equation you get at the end is 1 minus 2
it you notice something's gone wrong you
like oh that's ok it's clearly not 1
minus 2 it's that's going in the wrong
direction
let's reconfigure and see what went
wrong then we can fix it that make sense